the busiest US border crossing is open
again this morning after a confrontation
forced it to close temporarily yesterday
US Customs and Border Patrol agents
fired tear gas at hundreds of people
including women and children after some
of them tried to force their way across
the border between San Diego and Tijuana
Mexico thousands of migrants are waiting
in that area still they're upset about
the slow pace of the u.s. Asylum process
Mireya Villarreal is in Tijuana outside
the San Ysidro Port of Entry mateo good
morning to you well good morning this
official port of entry the busiest in
the Western Hemisphere was shut down
yesterday for five hours after the
clashes Mexican police tried to break up
protesters and that's when some made a
run for the border that's the sound of
tear gas being fired at migrants Sunday
after they rushed the border between San
Diego and Tijuana Mexico police started
throwing tear gas at us this migrant
from hundred I said there were many
children who fainted video from a
Mexican news channel appears to show a
Border Patrol agent yelling at migrants
nearing the border to get back
he then fires rubber bullets and people
scatter
it was like something out of a movie
this migrant woman said everyone started
running
Mexico's interior ministry said around
500 migrants tried to violently enter
the u.s. Sunday US authorities claimed
some of the migrants threw rocks and
other projectiles at US Customs and
Border Patrol in recent weeks thousands
of mostly Central American migrants have
arrived in Tijuana by Caravan more than
5,000 migrants have been camped out in
and around a Sports Complex hoping to
soon seek asylum in the US but fewer
than a hundred asylum petitions are
being processed at the San Ysidro Port
of Entry a day after clashes near the
official port of entry yesterday it was
quickly closed in both directions by
border agents an unusual move at the end
of a busy holiday weekend people on foot
and in cars waited in long lines for
several hours late Sunday night the port
was reopened and as cars began filing in
people cheer Mexican authorities say
that they have arrested a 39 migrants
and they plan to deport anyone who tried
to enter the US illegally
the Mexican government also says that
since mid-october when the caravan first
started to arrive here they have
deported nearly 11,000 people Central
Americans back to their home countries
John Maria thank you